HENRY SHACKLETON: I would say
that the thing that really
helped me the most
in Junior Lab develop
as learning how to do
experimental physics
is the lack of a super precise
direction in the lab guide.
So the lab guides are vague.
They are very helpful,
but they don't tell you
your sources of error
are this, this, and this.
You really have
to think about it.
You have to fill in the gaps
and essentially almost come up
with your own experiment
to determine how you're
going to go about the
analysis, how you're
going to go about the error
propagation-- things like that.
So I think leaving
that room for students
to figure things
out on their own
while providing feedback
and advice is very helpful.